Chris: Welcome, Ryan Reynolds
Ryan: Hello Hall H!
Chris: to Hall H.
Please, stand there and let seven thousand people spew their love at you.
Wow
[CROWD CHEERING]
How is it going?
Looks like we're ready to make the Chimi-fucking-changas around here
It's only been 11 years in the waiting
Chris: I know, how? I mean, for you to see this up there, to see you as Deadpool
One year ago to almost today some asshole in here leaked that footage
and that's why we're standing here.
I mean, Tim Miller, the director, we just sat back there and just shook our heads
in kinda awe just thinking "How did we get here?"
It was that, that moment, you guys, the internet, fans, you guys made the studio do this
you bent their arms behind their backs, twisted their friggin' necks and here we are.
I know people are very excited.
I think, let's-let's bring everyone. First of all, let's bring Tim Miller out.
Ryan: Yes!
Chris: Uh, Director Tim Miller out here.
And also, uh, as Vanessa, Morena Baccarin!
Chris [to Tim]: Nice to meet you.
Uh
As Weasel, as Weasel, my good friend, Mr. T.J. Miller is also here.
[CROWD CHEERING]
You gotta do warm-up
T.J.: Yeah, thank you, Chris.
Thank you, T.J.
Uh, as Negasonic Teenage Warhead, Brianna Hildebrand
[CROWD CHEERING]
As Ajax, Ed Skrein!
And as Angel Dust
Gina Carano!
[CROWD CHEERING]
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Please, everyone, have a seat
next to your name
Ryan [speaking with the voice of Don LaFontaine]: In a world divided by
T.J.: Yeah!
Chris [to Ryan]: You could just do that from now on. You could just do that
Ryan: I know, I do it all the time. It drives my wife nuts.
Chris: Alright, so, Tim, uh, let's start with you.
Tim: Let's not start with me
Chris: You don't wanna start with you?
Chris: It all starts with you!
Tim: Let's start with Ryan
Ryan: Oh, get in there. Give Tim a question.
He'll be great, trust me.
[CHRIS, TIM AND CROWD LAUGH]
Chris: Tim, what is, what is love?
Tim: Uh, It's a man named Ryan Reynolds
Chris: Yes!
Ryan: Wow
Christ: that's the perfect answer
Ryan: thank you, jeez.
Chris: So, uh, people love this character and they've been dying to see
this get its own movie for a long time
Can you, can you talk about, you know
what made you decide like this is something that we're gonna do
now is the time, we can do this, we have the time and resources
Tim: Uh, Fox said: "you can make it if you want"
and I said: "okay"
I mean, that's pretty much it!
I would've made this fucking movie anytime, but
It had to come at the right time
and the studio was ready to make it now
and I think it's because, as Ryan said, it's the fans. You know?
Ryan: Absolutely. Yeah.
Tim: He's the- He's the perfect character for our time.
I think
Chris: Yeah
And, Ryan, why do you think people are so in love with Deadpool?
Ryan: I think this character inhabits a space in the comic universe that no other person can or will ever inhabit.
I mean, you know,  it's got everything you'd ever want
You know, for one I just think it's an absolute
miracle that a studio let us make Deadpool
let alone a rated R Deadpool
[CROWD CHEERING]
Chris: But-
T.J: YEAH!
Chris: But I mean you-
T.J.: YES!
Chris: But you have to. You would have to do it this way
Chris: There's no way-
Ryan: That's US talking
Ryan: That's not the people that cut the big fat check
Chris: Did you have to convince them of that?
or did they just say: "Hey man, do whatever you wanna do with this"?
Tim: Uh, eventually they said that.
But at the beginning, I mean it is.
But they didn't say that at first.
It was R, then it was PG then it was R again
Ryan: Yeah
Tim: But
But ultimately, you know, I think they see that the world is ready for something different.
Ryan: No matter what the rating is though
Babies will love this. I'm telling you right now
Chris: It's gonna be feel-good baby movie of the year
Ryan: For sure, 100%
Chris: Do you feel like Deadpool is your soul
Do you feel when you put on the suit
you're like "yeah, I'm this guy"
Ryan: Oh no. That's-we put that suit on. It's just that the whole energy and atmosphere on the set changes
Ryan: I mean, I've, I've-uh-
Morena: Not to mention the smell
Ryan: Yeah, it's-
T.J.: The smell changes dramatically
Ryan: that thing takes a beating
I mean it was just- and it's sort of meant to be slightly disgusting
which is also a nice thing. It's all sewn up shoddily by Deadpool himself, but uh
Yeah, it's uh. It's definitely a game changer, you know?
I mean, I've only ever done one other like proper, full
Uh, sorry, not proper, Superhero movie, but uh
But, I didn't have a suit, you know?
It was a- It was a computer generated suit
So I never got to experience what that was like
to walk onto a set fully embodied-
Chris: and you don't get to talk that much!
Ryan: No! Yeah, This time I don't shut up
Yeah, yeah, no.
Uh, Morena, can you talk a little bit about Vanessa and just anything?
Morena: Anything?
Morena: I'll say anything, sure.
Chris: Anything you want like
Chris: who, who is she? What [mumbling] anything
Morena: She's-I mean she's a badass it was really awesome to read the script
Specially as a woman you don't-you don't get to read many superhero movies that have a badass
romantic lead in it
Um, and she, you know she gives them lip right back
not necessarily the talking kind.
Ryan: Oh
Um, she's just really awesome
She's a really, you know a perfect match to his crassness.
Chris: Uh, T.J.
T.J.: Yes, Chris.
Chris: Hi, T.J. Miller!
T.J.: Hi, Chris Hardwick. How are you?
Hello, Comic Con! This is my first time coming.
Thank you guys for having me. It's very crazy
Chris: are you serious?
T.J.: Yes. Seem wary, but thank you.
Chris: I mean for crap's sake!
You would think HBO would bring Silicon Valley to Comic Con
[CROWD CHEERING]
T.J.: Why are we gonna bring a show about Northern California Silicon? Forget that
Chris: What are you gonna do about that. That's crazy
Chris: We wouldn't understand. We're different States!
T.J.: Chris, I wanna tell you that they say we're promoting an R-rated film
the first real R-rated superhero film
On the back of these it says:
"Please be aware that many members of your audience maybe under 18 years of age"
and to those of you I say you're gonna fucking love this movie
Ryan and Chris: Yeah
[CROWD CHEERING]
Ryan: Amen
Chris: Yeah
Chris: I think we [LAUGHS]
I think we blew passed that barrier when we showed the first part of this
I think we're-everyone's totally, to say.
You kids have the internet now! You're desensitized of this shit, come on!
Ryan: yeah
T.J.: Most of you have seen horses fuck before you kissed your first girl
Chris: Alright, good. Well, let's go there
Let's go there, then.
[CROWD LAUGHING & CLAPPING]
Chris: Let's-let's go there
Chris: You know why T.J.?
Because it's unbridled passion
T.J. [LAUGHING]
Chris: It's-
Ryan: Heh! Well, I'm bridled. Wow, well done.
Chris: It's unbridled passion
T.J.: Oh my God!
Chris: and I just get bored of people after a while
Ryan: right?
T.J.: Oh, Chris. I eat your seabiscuit in the night
Chris: Giddy up, Teej (short for "T.J.", I think)
Chris: Uh [LAUGHS]
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Chris: Bria- [LAUGHS]
T.J.: And I play Weasel. Go ahead.
Chris: You play- [LAUGHS]
Ryan: Well done.
Chris: I think you gave us a sense of who Weasel was
T.J.: I think so, yeah!
Chris: Uh, Brianna, what can you-what can you tell us about your character?
Brianna: Um, so I play Negasonic Teenage Warhead
And she is-yeah! And she is a 15-year-old like superhero in training
She's Colossus' trainee
Um, and yeah. She's pretty gothic, apathetic
Um, and she's a very strong, young superhero who's a female and I love her.
Chris: Excellent
And what was the experience like for you coming into the cast
and where do you see yourself fitting in
I mean, was the shoot grueling, was it fun?
Brianna: No
Chris: was it a dream come true?
Brianna: It was so fun. Um, it was all fun
And it was such a dream come true 'cause I
may or may not have had a huge crush on Ryan Reynolds growing up, so.
Chris: What?
Brianna: And this was my first like film really, so
I had no idea what to expect but, it was so fun
and like, the energy among everyone was great
and we all got along great and yeah, it was awesome.
Chris: I mean, yeah, you know, when
When the lead character is like that actor really sets the tone of the set
and so, when it's someone like you and it's someone who's nice and fun
you have T.J. on there too, I mean it just, it sounds
Brianna: Oh yeah. It's so easy to be relaxed, yeah.
Chris: Yeah
Brianna: So
Ryan: Sounds like we're going into overtime
Tim: She actually showed me this photo of her photoshopped with
That photo of Ryan where he's like super like
12-pack muscles and she photoshopped herself into the
Brianna: I photoshopped myself into that
Tim: photo next to Ryan when she was in High School
Tim: She really did have a photo
Chris: did you show him that?
Brianna: Yeah, I did. I printed it out
Chris [TO RYAN]: What do you say to that?
Ryan: I guess I was her Joey Lawrence
That's who it was for me
I photoshopped myself into every Joey Lawrence photo I could find
and I feel ya. I feel your pain.
Chris: Well we have a special guest. Joey Lawrence is here!
Ryan: YES!
Chris: That would be amazing
Ryan: Woah!
Chris: Oh, that would be amazing
Chris: Woah. No he's not. Teej, I'm sorry
Ryan: Woah
Chris: I was just doing a bit.
T.J.: Chris, god.
Chris: I didn't mean to tear out your heart
Ryan: Ok, T.J., stay with us. You're okay. It's okay.
Chris: T.J., later we'll go to an equestrian center
[CROWD LAUGHING]
T.J.: You're really gonna stir up some controversy with these sorts
Chris: I'm gonna stir it up? You said the horse thing
T.J.: It's stir up like...
Chris: Stir up. Well done.
Well done, well done. Good, good.
You've saddled me with another bit
Uh, thank you. This is what we do all day.
This is the shit we do all day
Ryan: Wow, It's good
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Chris: Hey, alright
Now that was. No, you're right. No points for that one.
T.J.: Come on, come on. They're chomping in the bit for the rest of the panel, please.
Chris: Ed, what can you tell us about Ajax?
Ed: Um, Ajax runs the workshop that Wade Wilson comes to as a uh
terminally ill X-special forces soldier
and we uh, we give him the superpowers that turn him into Deadpool and um
He's very disrespectful and ungrateful.
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Ryan: Alright
Chris: That doesn't seem right. That seems very
Chris: That seems very threatening
Ryan: No, that's-that's about right.
Chris: Do you feel you owe them something? You feel like you should owe them anything for this?
Ryan: Of, for the superpowers?
Chris: Sure!
Ryan: No, you should see what they turn me into, though.
That's uh, I think it's a fair trade.
Chris: Yeah
Chris: Let's talk uh. I want to talk to Gina about Angel Dust
What can you tell us about Angel Dust?
[CROWD CHEERING]
Gina: I basically feel like we're creators
with uh, I mean, personally I have, uh
Angel Dust has a lot of anger issues
Um, so, we helped create Mr. Deadpool
and it's been kind of like a revolution
Um, I can't, I mean I'm looking out here and it's just such a massive event
And um, it's such a pleasure to be a part of it with this cast and the crew
and Tim Miller. Thank you for giving me the opportunity to be a part of it
Um, and thank you for allowing me the outlet to have
my anger issues resolved.
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Chris: Now, when you-obviously there's this irreverent tone that is necessary
to bring this on the screen
You obviously chose the right cast
How much was there riffing on the set or screwing around or did you allow that to go on?
Tim: Oh, fuck yeah, I mean the whole
First of all, I can't stop it. Um, Ryan does it non-stop
and T.J. is completely uncontrollable
T.J.: Professional
Tim: I mean, really
Tim: Even when I would get angry at him and tell him to quit fucking around he would still
still do it but everybody was great
I mean, we had a great set for a first-time director
It's gotta be one of the best experiences I could hope for
because we had no drama, no difficulty
the studio was behind this for all the decisions
They didn't question anything that we did
Uh, even though they probably should have
Morena: I think Tim was the biggest drama on set, right?
Tim: Yeah. I'm a bit of a prima donna
Tim: very needy
Morena: The stuff that comes out of your mouth
Tim: Ryan had to hug me at least twice a day
Ryan: Ugh, he's such a cry-baby, God!
He's such a pervert, too. Everything that he-
This guy cries if he sees unadulterated rage
Like, it's like it like gets him
Tim: It's true. Ryan did this scene where he comes in at a pivotal part of the movie that I won't tell you about
and he's just so fucking angry and Ryan's this thing, he's like:
"Dude, I got like two fucking takes in me for this because I'm [GRUNTS]"
But it was brilliant! And so I choked up a little bit
Ryan: I found him weeping in the corner afterwards
Tim: It was so good.
Ryan: I was like [GRIMACES] like non of the funny-dramatic stuff does it
just the pure rage. You should direct the next Hulk
You'd just be crying like a baby the whole time behind the monitor
Tim: I cry for the emotional stuff
Ryan: Then direct an episode of Nancy Grace
Tim: and then he got really jealous
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Tim: And then Ryan gets really jealous because on the third act Morena did this amazing scene
and I teared up again and then he did his side of it
and I was like "yeah, that was alright"
He's like "Where's my tears?"
Ryan: No, no
Chris: Were there things that you felt like "oh well maybe this is one step too far or maybe this is one step too"?
Morena: Only everyday
Ryan: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah
Morena: Every scene
Ryan: Yeah, there's stuff that I like would get home
I would be lying awake in bed and I would text Tim just to say:
"hey, that thing I said, that extra joke at the end of that scene when I'm walking out of the cab,
could you make sure that's never seen by anyone?"
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Ryan: Because there's a number of organizations that will find me
Tim: There was a rewrite T.J. Miller got involved in one of the scenes
and he wrote some of the meanest jokes
That's where I really said "you know we can't do this 'cause this is funny as shit but it's fucking mean"
It's just mean
Gina: Thank you! thank you and when you're-
T.J.: I am not mean!
Gina: when you're on the opposite end of those jokes.
You're laughing and crying and then you go home and you literally cry.
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Thank you
T.J.: It's true. I saw-Ryan's very strong, I don't know if you know ladies but he has a very muscular body
He's a strong man. And he was really sweet because when Tim would cry
he'd hold him like the little true, big baby that he is
[CROWD LAUGHING]
He'd rock him back and forth until Tim [MAKES SLEEPING AND SNORING SOUNDS]
Ryan: Yeah
T.J.: Then we'd all put on the suit and fuck around
[CROWD LAUGHING]
Chris: So, what can you say about this version of Deadpool without-
Obviously without giving away too much
What can you say to people? What can they expect?
I mean, I know we got a glimpse of it before but what-
Ryan: Well, it's everything, you know, that we love about the comics, I mean it's-
We have a guy that obviously is gonna break the fourth wall
Ryan: You're obviously gonna see what
[CROWD CHEERING]
And this is just my opinion but I think the most faithful
adaptation of a supersuit from a comic to a movie I've ever seen
[CROWD CHEERING]
And that's [UNINTELLIGIBLE NAME] I gotta shout him out
Uh, we have the Merc with the Mouth
The mouth is not at any point in our film sewn shut
[CROWD CHEERING]
Chris: Was that a condition?
Ryan: Yeah
Chris: You're nor sewing this mouth shut
Ryan: It was the only thing-I wasn't even paid, they just promised me that on this movie.
But um, and yeah, you have your Merc with the Mouth
You have the guy that is uh, doing his best to annoy the living shit out of everyone around him 24/7
Tim: And, you know what? Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick, the writers too.
Where are they? They're somewhere.
[CROWD CHEERING]
They deserve a lot of credit because this script, barn on is the best script I've ever read
[CLEARS THROAT] I get choked up, It's so good.
Ryan: See what I'm saying?
Chris: No! What?
Tim: It's beautiful
Ryan: are you okay?
Tim: I do, the script is great and they were tireless about with me trying to get this movie made with Ryan
We never let up with the studio, just constantly annoying them
With e-mails to please make this movie. Rhett and Paul were there beside me the whole time saying
This is the best script we've ever written and it needs to be done, so.
Chris: Tim, you know, I gotta say
[CROWD CLAPPING]
Chris: We've never met before this moment. I didn't know this but I just
I see this crusty exterior and a chewy center inside that I really enjoy about you
Tim: Hottest middle-age director working
Chris: No! But you have to know that it's just important for this people to know that this is
that important to you, you know? Like this is a very
This is a very special and important character to people and so
If you came out like "yeah we made this hot superhero movie"
people would be like "fuck that guy!" But you, you know, like
You're sensitive and you love it and it means something to you and we actually
have some footage to show you guys because
[CROWD CHEERING]
Because you're good and you sat through a lot of T.J. and I making horse puns and so
I appreciate that and so let's show some never-before-seen footage
Chris: Come on, you guys! Ladies and gentlemen
Tim Miller, Ryan Reynolds and the cast of Deadpool!
[CROWD CHEERING]
[CROWD CHANTING "ONE MORE TIME"]
Chris: Well
I mean, okay
Okay, um
I'm gonna-first of all! I don't have powers that control this
but you know what? I do have a microphone so fuck it, let's show it again.
[CROWD CHEERING]